mix together flour sugar baking powder  and season make it well in the center  then simply beat six eggs together pour  into the well and whisk into the flour  then whisk in milk making the mixture  lovely and light next add the three  cheeses cottage cheese grated Monterey  Jack or cheddar and cream cheese and  then for extra richness knobs of butter  then butter a baking dish and pour in  your rich cheesy cheats souffle mix now  put in a medium oven and bake for 40  minutes until rich golden and puff to  perfection a stunning fuss-free souffle  that's ideal for brunch  I got that you got that nice crispy skin  on top you can see how much of the stock  has evaporated next add fresh chopped  tomatoes then cumin seeds and fry until  the seeds are fragrant and the tomatoes  are lovely and soft